primary elections held in five states
yesterday georgia featured the most
action trump-backed university of
georgia football legend herschel walker
easily won the gop primary for a u.s
senate seat controversial congresswoman
marjorie taylor-green fought off her
primary challengers to win that
nomination secretary of state brad
raffensberger lambasted by former
president donald trump for the 2020
election won big tuesday against a
trump-endorsed opponent and governor
brian kemp easily survived a primary
challenge from former senator and trump
favorite david perdue
governor kemp is with us tonight
governor congratulations on the win
thanks for joining us do you feel
vindicated today
oh thanks for having me brett no look
we're just glad to getting out of the
primary i'm honored to be the nominee
again i promised voters in 2018
if they made me their nominee i'd put
them first and ahead of the status quo
and the politically correct and i'd do
what i said i would do when i was
campaigning and that's what i've done
and i think they confirmed that last
night but the work ahead for us is is in
front of us we've got a lot of work to
do to make sure stacey abrams doesn't
become our governor or your next
president do you are you going to mend
ties with the former president it got
pretty ugly there for a while
well as i've said many times on the hard
working georgians bus tour you know this
is about georgians i've never said
anything bad about president trump i
don't plan on doing that i praised you
know him and his administration and vice
president pence for the work that they
did to help our state during the
pandemic and a lot of other things that
we worked on but this race and what i'm
running for is to be governor of georgia
you know i'm concerned and was concerned
yesterday with their endorsement with
their vote to be the nominee again and i
got to do that again in november and
it's my belief that all republicans are
going to come together to make sure that
stacey abrams doesn't win this race and
that we keep georgia moving in the right
direction you know unlike her brett i
believe georgia is the greatest state in
the country to live work and raise our
families and i'm proud we're the number
one state in the country for business
and that's what i'm working to keep well
she was asked about that statement
here's her response to that
i think it was an artfully delivered
my point was a point that i've made many
times there may have been a a phrasing
that i could have done better but my
intention and my re and the reality is
true and that is brian kemp doesn't care
about certain communities in the state
and she went on to defend that saying uh
going right to
the issue of guns and saying that your
record on guns in georgia is going to be
a big part of this election
what do you think about what she said
and that issue in your election upcoming
well she's trying to mask over what the
real issues are in the state of georgia
which is 40-year high abiding inflation
she criticized us sending a billion
dollars back to the taxpayers instead of
wastefully spending it to help them
fight prices at the grocery store we
suspended the gas tax for over two
months to help lower the price at the
pump to help offset disastrous domestic
energy policies she criticized that she
wants to raise taxes uh you know she she
doesn't you know she she and her party
they want to defund the police well in
georgia we've been standing with law
enforcement and we've been going after
violent criminals but we also have just
passed the mental health parity act and
a lot of other things to address issues
that we have in our state and that's
what i'm looking forward to campaigning
on is my record because i have one and
the record that she has is that she
thinks she knows better what georgians
should be doing in the government than
our own citizens and that's what i'm
fighting against governor there are a
lot of people looking at the issues and
you're right to say democrats are behind
the eight ball when it comes to
inflation
and
crime even immigration in some places in
some states maybe georgia but on the
issue of abortion we could have a roe v
wade decision uh that affects some races
and on back to the guns georgia gun laws
you have permit less carry effective as
of april 2022 it's it now generally
permits any lawful weapons carrier to
carry handguns openly or concealed in
most public spaces without any
background check or permit required you
know in the wake of what happened in
texas there's going to be a big push
well brett that that's not that's not
correct i mean everybody's still got to
follow the law when it comes to
background checks it's just that you
don't have to have a piece of paper from
the government to carry now to carrick
if they're saying that that's that's
that's not that's not correct
and look the democrats and stacey abrams
call
this criminal carry well i got news for
them the criminals already have the guns
they're the ones that are doing uh these
terrible violent crimes they're the
members of the gangs that we're going
after what we're trying to do is give
law-abiding citizens the ability to
protect and defend themselves because
they're fed up they're fed up with a
local a lot of local politicians that
won't allow their police to go after
these people local prosecutors are not
prosecuting these individuals and
locking them up for violent crimes and
they have get out of jail free policies
and i've been a governor that's been
doing something about that because
that's what jordans want they're scared
to death when you can't allow your child
to go pump gas or go to the mall there's
a problem that needs to be addressed and
we have been doing that in the great
state of georgia
governor last thing you know in that
election last night secretary of state
brad raffensberger got more votes
than former senator david perdue
obviously the former president was
trying to take raffensberger down after
the 2020 election and was supporting
david perdue what do you think that
result says is georgia now past the 2020
election is that the message what is the
message
well i hadn't had a whole lot of time as
you can imagine to crunch the numbers
and see how everything fell out last
night i mean we were focused on making
sure that we won our race and making
sure that we're regrouping today and
getting ready for this fight because
it's going to be the number one watch
governor's race in the country it'll
probably be the most expensive
but i would just tell you i think
georgians they voted for people last
night that had a record that has been
putting them first ahead of the status
quo and the politically correct and i
know that's what i did
that record i've had a lot of people
help me with that members of the general
assembly speaker ralston lieutenant
governor duncan a lot of other folks
been engaged in that fight and that's
what we got to do but but the fact is
we've got to come together now
and win in november and that's what my
mission is going to be and i think it
will be of the citizens of our state
governor kemp as always we appreciate
your time